40. but hey there we go let's go live i
am going live i couldn't
click the button right it wasn't
available
all righty we're back in action mother
let me just fix this mother
we're going to pull the supes back up
the super chats guys let us know if
we're coming through
oh good the stream elements bots running
why not
turn it off uh
no turn the stream elements off we're
going to fix this guy he'll
give us one second all righty welcome
welcome welcome
oh good we're back barry turn back time
and save the livestream
yes we're back we didn't restart the
computer we just ran the other way
really hard we're doing this hit that
like button let people know we're here
hit that like spread it around
tweet it how do i find the uh scream it
from the rooftops where's the chat
to the previous one oh because the
stream ended yeah yeah so you'll have to
pull that video up
all right but we can still manage uh we
can still check everybody's uh
contributions
uh and we can still continue addressing
continue as normal people
takes questions and otherwise
yeah yeah yeah yeah just like leave a
comment here
all right open up all the necessary
windows all right
well we had 1200 people who are now not
informed that we're back to being live
everyone's just like bye
just hit that like button hopefully
people will notice it we used up all of
our notifications
that like hopefully we get the other
thousand people to know that we're here
yes we love one minute as we're letting
this page load back in and we're gonna
continue the stream as normal all right
all right
we gotta get people back in all right
all right all right
setting up the stream again and now
we're going back to the
contributions i ran out of
uh or ran out of uh okay so everyone use
the mac sword
we do let's go to the real rejects page
we gotta
we gotta is is that other the other one
stop being live right
all right just letting letting the live
stream live for a little bit hopefully
people find it
alrighty all righty all righty we're not
longer than the snyder cut yet
we are getting close but not yet all
right we're getting so close to back
where we were
before hold on guys we're going to get
your memories sylvester surprise in june
thank you to everyone who's returned
and hopefully we get the other 1200
people to get notified that we're back
so did we leave off i think on the life
of nate yeah correct
all right we are on the life of nate
let's bring that
super chat back oh look we're back in
business we got so many questions we got
to get through we're back in business
here i was thinking i was going to hang
out with my buddy at 8 pm
bring him into the stream all right guys
hopefully the other people noticed this
so yeah but life of nate you were the
last question we answered
we answered your question in detail yes
yes great big detail
all right cool here we go all right so
let's hope the 1200 other people will
get notified that this is out
yes partners like [ __ ] this we can't
click on this a third time part two
something's
darker uh no this is the last one we
ended up on was the cinematography
yeah what i wanted to say is picking up
the stream from where we left off
what i wanted to say was um
whoa what was he gonna say oh boy all
right so we will get we will get to all
these
what i wanted to say was that um
a shot that really stood out to me
actually was a restored version of when
commissioner gordon is looking up at
batman on the statue
because in justice league you have this
shot
that is blurred for some reason and i
notice
it's incredibly more effective in zack
snyder's justice league because that is
the first time in this
movie we are seeing bruce wayne
as batman on that gargoyle statue
so it's it just lends itself a much
greater
impact to shift the perspective away now
from
bruce wayne to commissioner gordon
looking upon
batman and um whereas in the justice one
you know he has the guy
from mine hunters and he's holding him
over the rooftop and his
he already knows about pair of demons
like he knows about all this [ __ ]
already
whereas in that moment having that shot
restored and coming in at that point in
time in
like an hour and a half into the movie
lends itself so much more power
as opposed to um you know what was there
before yeah great summertime
and and i mean the stuff that that zack
snyder re-shot to
like himself i'm always impressed by
like you know you know the nightmare
sequence had to be a lot of that but you
know like the fact that he
jumped behind the camera like robert
rodriguez style a little bit i thought
that was pretty sweet
um yeah thank you guys for agreeing here
yeah great cinematography
but we had 1200 people in here and bam
they're all gone
dusted away but hey for those who are
here thank you for being here for those
who have found this stream and hopped on
here
thank you so much for being here um let
me just fix a couple things here really
quick
[Music]
oh yeah and also thank you to nelson
ventura
and andrew just for the love that you
showed us today thank you guys
here your contributions mean a lot and i
hope you enjoyed justice league
um thank you both soap tape even though
it's not said in the movie after seeing
the film i have randomly been saying
unite the [ __ ] league throughout my
house
when i heard there was going to be an
f-bomb in here that was my first thought
unite the [ __ ] [ __ ] league and uh
and then
bruce wayne i mean cyborg gets an f-bomb
yeah um
but bruce wayne he gets that f-bomb
there
and i thought it was used really natural
i didn't see i didn't see the f-word
coming
i will [ __ ] kill you yeah yeah yeah
like that was used in a really natural
way and um it does
seem like like i don't know people were
always kind of up and people were like
[ __ ] debating like can't believe
bruce wayne swears says the f word i'm
like
[ __ ] you think this guy ever said the
f word a lot
easier time building he swears than like
if people get up in arms about him using
guns you can't get up in arms about him
swearing
like you know it's one of the other
there's a is there a third f-bomb
or or or am i missing one three f-bombs
no i think there's two f-bombs
okay that's yeah if anyone in the chat
can clear that up for us
keep an f bomb counter all right where
are
we
at hold on just adjusting this well yeah
way yeah
there you go there you go this is the
behind this this is like a behind the
scenes look but also a real
live stream stream
oh yeah so that you can see
and read more clearly
oh wow it's okay
we were we were on a two block one sec
you guys are seeing just how far behind
we are oh i was like
one second one second there we
all right john you take this away while
i adjust something here
all righty jacquarry marshall says they
said
boxes were destroyed uh where
uh were they destroyed just by
separating them
uh that's a good question i i mean
that's
i guess if that was the case that's what
i would guess because you know they
pretty much had fused and almost reached
their intended purpose only to be ripped
apart
i mean i gotta imagine that there's
still some juju left in those boxes
but you know it certainly makes them a
lot less powerful when they're apart
but am i missing something or i don't
know the answer to that to be honest
i couldn't tell you definitely what you
said sounds pretty good to me
yeah yeah yeah uh let's see here i
appreciate what everything you guys are
saying here hit that like button guys it
would really help with getting those
1200 people we lost back in the stream
hey we're 20.
it's not just something i'm saying guys
that's a real thing it will help us out
absolutely so if you guys can just go
ahead and hit that like button
i mean a lot chat in the chat but if
there's a way to leave a comment
leave a comment any and all engagement
gets it to the people
i mean damn [ __ ] this is a really good
viewed live stream for us so far
yeah uh one's the best viewed live
stream
ever for us i'm just pinning this one
and the
other post is a little behind the scenes
knowledge here i'm just pinning this one
in the other live stream
that way people can know that way people
can know that there's a whole other part
to indulge upon if i happen to find the
first one instead of this one
ah it's been it's it's it's it's it's
it's nice
to have you guys just the few of you who
found this
first though you guys are rock man you
guys are the diehards appreciate it i
know you care the most
appreciate it um let's see here okay
we're getting up though we're getting
back
up there here we go here we go are we
back to being focused we are all right
sylvester fryson jr what did you think
of the fight in themuskira for the
motherbox
fantastic i mean we we talked about that
in pretty big depth earlier
but yeah the the choreography of you
know
one little detail i love because since
we already talked in depth about it and
appreciate your super chat um
the blonde girl who has the arrow that
that rush of urgency where she's tying
it up
and then she like shoots it how she
comes back
in the age of heroes flashback fight
like there's a close-up on her and
you're like oh damn she's been around
since
then which makes her death suddenly hold
more weight
yeah even though i held it down for so
long yeah even though i don't know who
this person is
you know like it held that much like a
little nugget of detail like that
actually holds a lot of weight but yeah
um go watch the other stream
billy the kid lawrence oh
oh greg and john are a totally jumbled
nice to see you back here tj tj you got
a whole different name what's the story
morning glory
nice to see you you're gonna have to
enlighten us miss you how's your
daughter
mariah hey guys
missed you you are really crushing it
lately and it's great how is the movie
going greg
movie is slowed the [ __ ] down for behind
the scenes reasons i cannot unveil of
things that other people
are currently working on that are gonna
be big and i'm hoping
i can at least get the down low on a
couple of things to keep this channel
thriving
while the casting process for the thing
i'm working on with them
is getting slowly filled so it's an
incredibly slow delayed process
i kind of wish i didn't say anything but
it's my snyder cut already
it will come out releasing the correct
petition in the description if you don't
know what i'm talking about announcing
about something that the team wanted me
to announce
but um no but just wait but i appreciate
that maria i
appreciate you tristan michael really
confused about batman in this movie
correct me if i'm wrong but doesn't both
the law and media hate him
why is everything all cool now well i
don't think the
media hates him it doesn't seem like i
felt like that was the problem at bvs
was that everyone was covering superman
and like oh
we could we trust him and the media
clerk
was as cleric the reporter was like i
want to talk about batman
and then yeah white is like no one cares
about batman
cover football that's what people want
to hear about
nobody cares about a bat and i think
that was an
argument was that yo no one gives a [ __ ]
about batman in the media
i mean it seems like gotham is a bad
enough place
that like you know i mean he's he's
taking care of business he's clearly got
his relationship with gordon it seems
like yeah
batman just kind of gets to do his thing
and i mean i feel like you can
link an argument to that of like well
clark wanted to dig into batman and he
was just further proof that the media
i guess like's a hero they know the home
origin of
rather than a hero from outer space or
something yeah
yeah all right one second give me one
second
hold up one second
just soak in a moment john what's the
next question the next question i'm
pushing a push in the hangout
but with a vaccinated friend right now
safety first andrew mcgregor
50 000 planets
destroyed is the punishment of a
scorndex girlfriend that repeatedly
brings up arguments you had years ago oh
oh golly you must have had some pretty
heavy arguments in your damn life jesus
hear that while sending a text message
is like really daunting
never ended a fight with a with a with a
significant other that was like
you owe me worlds societies
then again all he's saying is the
punishment of a scorn next go for their
freedom
okay who have you been dating i missed i
misheard that in my
when you were talking as i was
multitasking there yes
i mean it is either that or a scorned
family member what did darkseid do do
you guys know what darkseid did
i don't know what darkseid actually did
you steppenwolf
i mean steppenwolf to be in that
position to oh so crazy much uh
yeah it's a great that's a great
question he [ __ ] up
i'm actually not familiar with what he
did guys enlighten us
what did why why hashtag justice for
steppenwolf
i feel like what happened in our last
stream was that people were like
the 1200 were like you know what it's
over
we're all leaving i don't need to check
you back in
yeah they meant to end it that way
that's how this was supposed to yeah
that's that's the other chat oh it's the
wrong one yeah
okay where are we at we are uh there
yeah okay here we go
all right here we go yes yes oh we got
omni media next the man the myth the
legend media
joker asks how many times alternate
timelines they have destroyed like with
flashpoint
what if the nightmares are residual
memories on one of those timelines
because it's already happened hence the
bvs flash scene i'm too early
my brain hurts it's a good theory that
would be cool i mean
i don't know how to really comment on
that i feel like that's almost a near
perfect theory
i would love to see something like that
happen and to get like even more
sci-fi about it and like really screw
with that stuff of like what it does to
your mind to collide and cross
dimensions and whatnot like i i want
your release the omni cut see that's
what i think the time travel [ __ ] that
flash did
might have started this effect yeah as i
was talking about in the earlier part of
this
in part one on part one of this stream
which you should have come over from
how um uh you know a [ __ ] um
uh fly like maybe what flash did is a
big part of what's
messing with because it's like this
bruce wakes up from a dream with flash
coming to him
but is that a dream or did he actually
time travel you know like there's got to
be something
there's got to be some weird things of
happening of timelines colliding
i would say so i mean to me that always
read like
more than just a dream oh it easily was
yeah
uh jimmy thank you for that question on
me i actually i'm gonna roll with that
theory and act like it's mine i'm gonna
steal it
yeah jivi uh feature it was going to be
revealed that during superman's absence
bruce impregnated lois which is why the
kid wouldn't have powers and become the
new batman
wow i just love how i love how you said
this that
bruce just impregnated lois
he just yeah he's sent to vile you want
my sieben
no they had a relationship he just did
it don't started they started to happen
it started having a relationship of
sorts and then he
got her pregnant he'd just impregnate
her he was a one-night stand
brought her back to the cave and then
kicked her out the next morning no it's
like some pearl harbor [ __ ] right there
yeah absolutely
that's a michael bay pearl harbor [ __ ] i
mean
i i could see it happening they would
just have to really live in it
and i would almost be taken aback if
that if that gets paid off her grabbing
the pregnancy tissues
oh [ __ ] did sleeping with bruce wayne
now that superman's back did
did something happen like i would be i
would be a little taken aback by that
but if they if they lived in it it would
be cool
all right yeah i mean i you see in one
scene where
superman's when darkseid puts his hand
on him i'm assuming that's lois
who he's holding in his arms right is
that who that was
he's only the same thing like a burnt
skeleton seems like it would be
to me oh man or it was just uh it was
that russian family's body
families bought it just like oh they
never even got to see the light of day
in this cut
your boy mirage mari you are not the
father
superman that's what happens man
if batman if it's batman's kid i mean
look if if tycho waititi were to step in
and take over the franchise he could
which he should be on the mori show
yeah that's how it should open no it'll
end that way it'll be like joker
that's not my kid look at those bad ears
you get what you deserve throws a
batarang at maury's head
cam perroni hey really curious to hear
what are your thoughts on who's in the
open kryptonian pod in the ship
love your content your reactions bring
joys to bring joy to me
oh yeah that's right well it can't be
supergirl because supergirl is alive
and it can't be i don't i honestly don't
think it was anyone who
was that significant i think it was just
like
tony who failed to get the [ __ ] away
that's that's where i was playing
the lackluster answer as that is i think
that's what it is
i don't have a master theory like all
the important kryptonians we've kind of
were aware of it's jorrell's hologram
yeah he just goes in that pod sometimes
dedicated hologram he'll become a
skeleton if not using them
yes that's right man he's gotta he's
gotta preserve
you haven't used the codex in a few
years oh this is what you get yeah
didn't touch that skull one second
hmm thanks uh all right cool
is that brian nin or brienne
at the end it was originally supposed to
be two green lanterns visiting bruce
instead of martian manhunter
dude martian mantards was worth two
green lanterns
i mean i think what ended up happening i
like actually no i heard this story
um about how green lantern
he did want to use him and then warner
brothers stepped in and we're basically
like if you do this we're shutting your
movie down you cannot do this
wow like they stepped it really kicked
that was one of the story when i was
like
oh i heard about this story or do i want
to talk about the atm machine lady story
uh amanda apparently you chose wisely
but the green lantern
yeah they originally wanted green
lanterns to show up but um
warner brothers like they they said
absolutely not
or or hbo max i think it was warner
brothers and they
they were basically stepping in saying
like if we do this we're shutting your
movie down
jesus i wha there's so many things
coming from that side of the
conversation where i'm like
i wanna know why tell me why are you
guys
so uh uh yeah why are you guys so intent
on this
um but it would have been cool but at
the same time i think it worked out for
the best i think it's more rewarding
ultimately to be getting martian
manhunter than it is to be getting green
lanterns there
because martian manhattan just hasn't
been brought to the big screen yet yeah
it's more fresh
um god damn
i think this one's more canon you guys
are having an argument in discussion
billy frischer thank you so much dude
buddy
do we answer this question love you all
my question is what do you all think
about
luther hinting at formulation did you
just ask did you see this question tight
twice
zach snyder's legion of doom i think we
should do it
do it we i think we answered this
question twice for you but i appreciate
it restore the eyes and verse
and i appreciate i really appreciate uh
you doing dual super chats here
that means a lot thank you all right
guys look we're doing the home stretch
we are in the home stream there's a
tease of how much is left see this
little scrolling bar
we got to make it we got just to
understand we got to make it up to here
and then we'll be cutting you off we do
not want to do some follow-up video we
want to honor
people who are here yes we're going to
power through i've been pushing
my vaccinated friend hang out before
anyone's like should you be seeing
people this vaccination is going to
expire
soon and he's going to have to get over
it
sorry man go away much later well i want
to make sure we're giving quality
answers to all you guys
we appreciate this and it's been fun as
[ __ ] too
um [ __ ] my friend [ __ ] you brandon i
hate hope you're watching mel
yeah you dick go [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
never speak to us again say why do you
keep pushing i'm on a live stream man
you wouldn't understand you wouldn't
understand pull it out
life brandon pull it up and just super
chat what you would have said to me
while we were hanging out now brandon's
great he's been one of our closers we've
known branson in second grade
and we got we got so many life moments
together ray gunner gaming
uh hey but billy thank you for such a
generous super chat that really means a
lot and uh yeah we're 100 for a legion
of doom we want to
i want to see it's just a focused movie
of them
ray gunner gaming hey not just not just
not a question just wanted to say thank
that you guys are awesome ray gunner
gaming
you're awesome thank you so much dude
love you really means a lot seriously
the support lately especially in the
past few months has been incredible
thank you
and we haven't been live in so long and
we haven't been live in so long that
we're like [ __ ] let's do a four-hour
live stream
but yeah what's up in so long let's just
do an
incredibly long life let's yeah you know
but hey you gotta
you gotta shake the rust off you know
we'll be super efficient
in a few months when the next livestream
happens
jeff hill do you think of uh
subscriptions blow up because of the
movie and audience girl right now seeing
a high 90s ron tomatoes that they could
do a justice league too
i mean let's face it people have wanted
the snyder verse to be restored
i think with the fact that like it's
crazy when you're seeing people like
reviewers i
watch uh people like damn merle who are
like crow
i really like this and i don't get how
the other one happens i really like this
a lot
this is pretty great you know and then
and first like i know dan was like i
didn't even care for man of steel or bbs
but this is great
you know and like my point being with
that is how you can
there are people who don't even like
those movies like man of steel or bvs
who are on board for this movie you know
that says a lot about the effect that
you don't have to just be a fan
of man of steel and bvs ultimate edition
like
sounds for a lot of people they can just
watch this one after those and be like
uh i don't like the other two but i
really like this one
i mean i i like the other two this
improved on them for me
like you know this is my favorite of the
three thank you jeff hill
baskin charge 1822. the batman and joker
conversation and gave me chills except
for the reach around line
laughing there was something a little
bit too much about that
yeah cause it's just like you know
there's a lot of gruff and adult stuff
about this movie but it doesn't really
jump into that uh corner of the video
store so yeah like some kind of
reach-around reference was just like a
a different tone than the rest of the
movie felt like
you know because there's not like like
any sex jokes or anything like that
except for that
you know um crimson daharic
thank you for that baskin charge crimson
the horik thank you so much for the
superhero
yeah i appreciate you playboy phil thank
you playboy
do you think they made flash faster than
the speed of light too soon before his
solo movie
i don't think they did i feel like what
they did was tap into a potential that
he might not know how to always activate
yeah or control or or yeah refine or
something like that
so yeah yeah i wish you could spend
longer on that but
but that's pretty much it yeah yeah i
think that they tease that he can do
this but i don't think
he can just be like all right guys i'm
gonna turn back time yeah
yeah i mean because this is in so many
ways a lot of their first day really on
the superhero
job and so it seems like he has a level
of awareness about what his capabilities
are but yeah
that he needs to really kind of explore
and hone them
um alto voltaje thank you alto we need
more weekly live streams
hey you know like it was just the kind
of the way the scheduling was going
with having to cover one division
pulling all nighters for that never
sleeping event yeah just
that was going like oh we got the new
rock stars to cover uh because we like
going those breakdowns was
was a big part of our journey with it
and like we wanted to do one for falcon
and winter soldier but
with the way the time was just presented
today and knowing we wanted to do this
live stream i was like
look i i'm supposed to be going out of
town i am going downtown
i'm going to town march 28th to april
2nd so i'm trying to get a week ahead on
patreon shows
we're like
not even a day ahead so like no we're on
track right now
all of all of our getting ahead has to
be done next week so it's probably going
to be even less youtube uploads next
week
so i was like i really want to commit to
making sure this is a
like a worthwhile live stream so to
everyone who's like i've been jumping
around at three different streams i
really appreciate it
i know we lost a lot of people from
hopping around to the third stream but
we got at least half of you here
so thank you so much um for being here
uh but yeah well like if we can do a
live stream we'll do a live stream
kenneth rathbun jr what's the
possibility that the premonitions were
given to bruce by martian handhender
i don't think that's the case at all i
don't see it coming there no no
i think martian manhunter has
intentionally been stepping away and it
would be kind of weird if you're like
i'm gonna give all these
premonitions to bruce wayne but i'm not
really gonna i'm not gonna get involved
with this
[ __ ] i'm not gonna get involved i'm not
gonna risk my ass over this jeez
um let's see here but thank you kenneth
i've heard that theory going around but
i don't think that's the case at all
randy pena next big weight is matrix 4
december 22nd i went in 19 years for
this film i have so many reasons why
this movie will change the game again
hashtag kiana sans
yes um matrix4 i
matrix one is probably my all-time
favorite movie tied with
t2 judgement day so as much as matrix
revolutions wasn't the greatest
uh i'm still excited for matrix four
absolutely man it says
and it's nice to take a quick break to
talk about the matrix
kit rupertson snacks next time john
snacks we need snacks we need snacks
that are easy to eat and speak
while we eat go see if i have anything
to munch on really do it man
i'm going to read kits rupertson's
question superman
blocking the axe with his shoulder was
awesome do you want to see shazam
in the dark shazam in the nightmare
reality absolutely man i feel like the
nightmare reality i want to see
as many dark takes as
they can justify in a reasonable manner
is what i would say to that
because uh yeah i mean you already get
the slight
peek at you know evil superman bizarro
superman whatever you want to call that
um and so yeah to see the shazam dark
version for a character that's
especially in the dcu way more towards
the front end of the spectrum
i i would be down for that kit rupertson
uh and i'm sure greg will have a thought
in a hot second looking at the regular
chat here uh eisenberg has a higher
ceiling to clear that's an interesting
one
uh then jared leto for the joker that's
a that's a that's a
big take right there and yes godot uh
gal gadot that does equal goddess i i
feel like
two dislikes on the stream are from
darkseid and steppenwolf i feel like
though
steppenwolf should like the stream
because we're like steppenwolf deserves
his due
man steppenwolf is kind of say he's he's
like kind of cute
he's see the problem is whenever anybody
writes low-key
but doesn't spell it like low-key i
think okay are you talking about loki
are you talking about loki
but he is i'm glad you find steppenwolf
cute though
cal blank and i feel like that is worth
a like in and of itself can we get this
concurrent viewers
to 666 oh no we already passed it
of a mephisto taco uh oh thanks do i
just finish the half or
or all right oh thank you you got a
quarter of the half
well i don't know i mean this is like
you don't have to feed me anything
so you know i'm just grateful here
yo guys where are we at taco time
so what'd you answer john kitt rupert
said hey you're answering that
dark shazam hello eat your taco and i'll
handle this one
no i'm gonna chew into the mic olivia
berry a liverion
desk has never cut the hair my fiance
would disagree
it's a little too long for her taste but
it makes my life easier just to have
like two looks
beanie or ponytail that's right down or
up
perfect so much easier just to be like
i'm going to rush
being your ponytail which one's it going
to be yeah and then when you really want
to feel nice you can get a third look
with the curls
um the price is right review
thank you here in the man of steel
flying music when superman arrived was
awesome i was cheering seeing superman
just cut loose on steppenwolf
that was one of the most badass scenes
that was one of the first things we
talked about in this stream
was him just pounding on him as if like
steppenwolf personally wronged him in
every room
i mean at this point he's basically the
surrogate for everyone who has wronged
him
how does that vegan taco it's so not
vegan tasting
i can't believe it's vegan i can't
believe it's not butter but but
it's delicious you guys should all be
jealous right now i really got excited
when you actually see silas stone
looking at the kryptonian ship
and then the superman music plays i feel
like zack snyder just really knew
like how to weave in the musical numbers
throughout this whole movie yeah
especially like the established motifs
and stuff and the light motifs and
everything
jaby kawai my brother my actual brother
what what'd you think of the
post-credits scene sequence
amazing too long i know this would be an
hour and a half movie without the post
credits
there was no post credit scene there's
no postcard that's the joke
he gave us a 50 super chat to make a
joke that's how much money that brother
makes
is comedy he just goes you know what's
funny
i can just afford fifty dollars i can
afford to make a joke a makeup
joke i don't have a question i'm not
going to add
a comment that is based on actual fact
so
this is so funny this is keeping them
coming here's my here's my silly joke
about how there's no post-credit scenes
keep them coming
i really do appreciate it that's
delightful
thank you thank you i will text you
expendable
foot clan soldier one dollar appreciate
it
i appreciate it man you're not
expendable i don't realize the one
dollars you can ask questions too
yeah i
the joker scene is genius zach shot the
scene with a very uneasy
unstable camera going in um and
out of focus making the audience feel
uneasy uncomfortable and just as
unstable as the joker
yeah and i feel like it also captured
the perspective of having a nightmare in
the way how bruce wayne is experiencing
it
i felt like it was real the whole scene
was captured from the pov of bruce wayne
oh yeah yeah and i mean
i love too that the way they shot it
enhances
how monstrous he looks and like the
makeup they have on his mouth and eyes
like the further out of focus it gets
the more they just look like black holes
in his head so like they really did make
the joker
not only maniacal and all the other
things that you love about the joker but
actually like
like scary in a in an uns uneasy kind of
way right
you know so yeah i thought that was
really cool the way they shot that jacob
winters jacob winners we we answered
your questions on stream elements sorry
we got around to it soleil but we did
answer your questions i know you had a
couple hell yeah
appreciate that i'm sorry i had to pop
on over here but uh thank you though if
we didn't ask
yeah c to the p what do you think
of my idea for house uh for house snyder
verse
should continue for how snyder versus
continue
one martian man hunter hbo series
two green lantern movie three cyborg
trio series four the flash movie five
wonder women three
s six justice league two
uh you want do you want to take this or
should i take this you take it away
i think this is the perfect slate
greenlight it now except wonder women
should be a mini series in and of itself
you know what
let's do this all different martian
manhunter movie
green lantern hbo series
cyborg movie the flash hbo series
wonder woman comic book only justice
league 2 is a video game
i've heard they're doing some pretty
great things for green lantern
have you yeah they're doing a lot of
practical effects oh
cool a lot of practical effects are
green lanterns no cg suit
no comment okay uh i have one ryan
reynolds one
tiny down low on that and that's working
on a lot of practical effects for this
one
hell yeah that's i mean that's gonna
have people happy in
itself um yeah it's gonna be great
thank you see the p nelson ventura i
think the girl at the start with wonder
woman is donna troy
oh is she like a wrestler or a fighter
or a bodybuilder what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
donna troy the what what woman with
wonder woman
i thought they talked about the little
girl
oh who could be anything she wants to be
yeah
but but her place of origins then
mascara
and her mom's hippolyta then you're
wrong nelson ventura not every theory
can come true
i'm sorry nelsonvintura but that's a
fair thing and a zack snyder versus
could be
yeah i mean she could have been sent
away superman style for some
odd reason that's true from themyscira
which is not
agoraphobic fanboy awesome to see you
guys back on the live stream thank you
for being
here good to see you adored the snyder
cut
um was everything i could have ever
wanted
loved your coverage thanks again for the
cameo by the way made me super happy oh
yeah well thank you so much for just
showing your support here in our super
chats buddy and for the wonderful review
on cameo
i know that was great it's a very loving
five-star review that we very much
appreciate guys we're on cameo
guys come get a shout out fifty dollars
a cameo shout out we think we're worth
it
we're being fair it's worth it 150 is
going to
change your life pierre
james we never promote or push so it's
always exciting when we get one we're
like oh a cameo once every four months
one comes in someone found it i'm one
yeah it feels the most rewarding when it
really is clear someone had to go
i wonder if the real rejects are on
cameo
um pierre jones if the cut was divided
into two parts which
scenes would have worked to end uh parts
one and two
when batman lands in front of
commissioner gordon
what's gonna happen next yeah right
before the [ __ ]
big action scene happens yeah we don't
want to go out on a bang
we want to start the next one with the
bang i mean it probably
would i don't think it would have worked
but
at the end of that chapter would make
the most sense
i mean i at risk of of of not putting in
the effort it seems
like you would the chapters are pretty
appropriately set up
so i feel like you would cut if any i
don't think you i don't know if there's
anything in part three that you could
like cut into the half of
well that's part four when that happens
okay
i think yeah i think
martin's getting kind of confused but
what uh my point with that is that um
this snyder is that uh like
you start to you you even recap some of
the mother box [ __ ]
with cyborg when he's talking and
explaining it to the team and how it all
works
so i think you can you could have
ended it there i just don't think i
think it still would have felt like
setup yeah
uh and so i i feel like it only works as
a four-hour film
yeah yeah because there's just not
enough conclusion
throughout the movie to kind of that's
the thing is is i feel like one thing
we've learned
is that you have to make even your
linear progressing story a uh you know a
move
if you're making a trilogy each one has
to have a beginning in the middle and an
end
basically basically
that's right
when did you realize john by mistake
stopped last streaming wait for some
time post that to see if you restart
but had to step out and here we go you
know
if you didn't accidentally do your
public stream
we would have had three notifications to
be able to get this
third live stream i think it's possible
for me to feel worse about this
no i i could go yeah i think it's
possible
yeah i that's a very valid point let me
get
a valid point very valid point i'm not a
big fan of stream elements
stream elements suckered me in with its
very familiar user interface
i don't i don't know it doesn't matter
now
but i appreciate that i appreciate that
you found us i was like this is going
too well i got to freeze this computer
somehow
percy tremblay sidebar congrats on the
falcon and bucky interview you two
deserve it watch you every day
love you too dudes thank you percy um
yeah
and i was like we're living high and
then tyrone drops a zack snyder
interview
no you son of a [ __ ] we'll get there
don't worry we'll we'll catch up someday
we'll catch up to the snyder man
stay gold bang are we just gonna ignore
that dark sides almost had green
lantern's ring that ring flew to him and
chose him
those gods got lucky i know that ring
was like
that's so true that ring was like
oh i don't know this guy seems powerful
this guy seems like he's got the ability
that's true the ring was choosing him
that's a sinister prospect i didn't even
think about that
great call stay cold we gotta explore
in the next green lantern maybe the ring
was just curious like a cat who thinks
there's
there what's the big deal what is
everybody fighting this guy
you do you do i go to you there's a lot
of people here to choose from let me get
a closer look
jose narv i thought the ring attack no
no the ring didn't attack he was going
for the ring and someone else attacked
him yeah
jose narv what do you think about zack
snyder's steppenwolf and how he
is i think he's well improved upon and
the one thing we haven't discussed in
this
video or the last is uh i liked his
armor
i liked his armor like had like a weird
little functionality where you could
tell like the different plates were
moving to like
vent depending on how he was standing
and so it was live and it was cool
yeah i think they do a great job at
subtly fleshing out how human um
steppenwolf really is like
he's like two different people when he
has the mask on and when he has the mask
off
the helmet i mean helmet on helmet off
he's like two very different people
i really like totally sad and kind of
vulnerable and weak
and then with the helmet on he's like
full of strength and ambition and fury
you get the sense that
it's like ah steppenwolf is probably
more the helmet guy
anymore than he is the not helmet guy
fluke newcomb amber heard is known as a
bad person but she's hot as balls so it
cancels out
ain't that the [ __ ] truth again
no comments
papa
i june we do the same thing with men in
a much weirder way you're charming
charming good actor why not yeah i like
characters you play who cares about life
until proven guilty then let's go fully
innocent
100 innocent until proven 100 percent
guilty
papa jin papajit joss is downgrade
pop thinks papagen just downgraded an
african-american actor story a gay
actor's character into mediocrity and a
strong female hero into a sex object
how did wb not think zack's cut would be
a winner
because i have a feeling some of that
was based on their notes
exactly like i don't think joshua eden
came in and was like here's my plan
100 right all right
where are we at here oh man we're doing
so good guys
we're climbing back we're doing so good
numbers all right so
so we can end at a reasonable time
because i could feel that jon and i are
both losing some energy
i'm not we got a lot of super chats to
get through
a lot of major contributions which i
really appreciate
and um we still got to refresh this page
to see what else we're missing out on
so we want to just make sure that we
catch up on all of them to honor
everyone who
showed the support there so i'll ask
that we would draw if anyone wants to
put any more super chat so you don't do
that right now cut off
cutting you off bars closed people well
you don't have to go home here only
people who already order their food
we'll be able to eat now you don't have
to go home but you can't stay here
no walk-ins no nothing s marie
s marie hey yes marie uh you go for it
i've seen callum jackson ask this a
million times in regular chat and i feel
bad
would you rather see joker or
deathstroke in a batman solo movie
um yes deathstroke
deathstroke i'd rather see deathstroke
in a solo batman movie yeah
at this point i feel like we've seen so
much joker batman and solo
solo batman and joker is like a given i
mean death's the reasoning that ben
affleck was giving to
to choosing deathstroke just made a lot
of sense
and i'm like yeah i want to see death
star why haven't we seen deathstroke
yeah he'd be [ __ ] incredible to watch
on big screen that arkham origins fight
that went viral for even for those who
haven't played the game
the reason why i fight so cool is how
we're like oh man i wish this was real
this would look so cool real you know
yeah so
yeah i would love i would love to see
deathstroke specifically i'm really
starting to lose my voice yes
deathstream you hear that in my videos i
can hear you getting all these gravel
really starting to lose my voice really
starting to lose that voice
did you might need to do a pick-me-up
stream to pick me up uh here uh for
another video because i was really
starting to lose my voice
farzeed ali
did you notice they played the initial
part of a beautiful lie
soundtrack of bvs in the batman joker
scene it was very subtly but so haunting
was it really i didn't notice it see
that those are the kind of like guides i
would like because yeah
i didn't pick it up but i would love to
see what specific
motifs and light motifs come back and or
maybe recontextualize because that was
part of the fun of one division two was
like there was a moment where it was
like oh you can hear a take a take
an interpolation of doctor strange's
theme and so uh yeah i love stuff like
that in these
the music in that scene definitely
worked i i like i noticed it obvi is
like the most obvious one was when
uh you see lexus escape prison and
there's some different bald guy in there
yeah
and you hear you hear the familiar tune
but i don't think i noticed that with
the batman joker scene
no look out for the workout for pregnant
lois and i gotta look out for batman
joker scene now thank you
the beautiful live soundtrack thank you
amanda doherty
the parts worked for me not just as good
break points but also because to me it
added the
to the overall operatic feel to the
movie which to me distinguishes it well
from marvel
thoughts i think the part the part the
parts chapter the pop
pop pop parts the parts chapters breakup
works so well
because it reminded me of when i read
the da vinci code
how there's there's so many chapters so
it makes the chapters feel extra short
that every time you get to another
chapter you're like i'm brazing through
this thing
let's keep going like it was such an
easy book to read because of the
simple mind [ __ ] of well man these
i'm breezing through these chapters yeah
so i i think that when you like get to
another chapter
you're just like i'm completing this
might as well keep going so weirdly by
doing that
you are getting the binge watch feel
yeah because you're like well i'm just
getting through in the next episode now
so actually it works really well
absolutely you're watching just four
episodes of television
yeah no i think the the parts worked
really well they felt natural within the
story and uh i mean
now there were quotes too yeah yeah
totally and now i'm just curious to see
i know zack snyder i believe said that
the actual theatrical
cut has a true intermission put in
between parts uh
for the theater too yeah yeah true
intermission between like parts
two and three or something like that or
parts one and two yep
you watch part one and you gotta sit
your ass down for the next
chapter it's after part four uh either
way yeah no i i do agree like that
operatic feel in that like big event
like yeah i thought the chapters thing
worked really well a roon a nun
dark side next next next
with earth with the lantern ring
everything with the omega beams
that is a callback not call back but
that is a joke
it's a reference reference that's the
word andy lee
do you think there could be a justice
league versus justice lords movie in the
future
not in the nearby world in the near
future
but maybe down the road yeah
20 30. i feel like down the road they're
going to start looking for like the next
biggest weirdest crossover ideas they
can do yeah
the new team the stuff because every
decade i feel like they're
like okay what have we not explored what
have we not done what have we not
brought to life
and [ __ ] like justice league versus
justice lord
yeah that's gonna it's gonna be a while
chase gardner
favorite bvs batman favorite bbs scene
batman warehouse scene
favorite new justice league cut scene
barry allen telling his dad he got his
foot in the door i
cried then good call when you see our
reaction
you'll see that's when we cried oh yeah
oh dude i'm even just getting flipped
on the door let them shake me
you got your foot in the door
i'll get shanked all day i would love if
that actually happens
next time you see me just full of holes
that's a great scene beautiful
performance from billy crud up there
absolutely beautiful ramon gallegos i
think that was montaged over in the last
one
just holds it up oh why i don't remember
i don't remember i hope you're
remembering poorly
roman gallegos what's up guys love your
guys's channel man
ha question what actors do you want to
see play as green lantern hal jordan or
jon stewart
for hal jordan i want to see finn
wolfhard and
jon stewart i want to see
millie bobby i want to see um
uh uh like keith stanfield i just feel
like he
you're like i i feel like weird about it
i'm not sure he'd be the right one
but he's an odd one enough that i feel
like he'd be a cool pick
yeah hal jordan though let's [ __ ] do
like some army hammer [ __ ]
some controversy that's the reference
let's get army hammer yeah
uh for me it would be i it would be
sebastian stan and anthony mackie there
you go
there you go respectively
oh golly george barrett
thank you ramon uh george barrett hopes
finding honesty in huge channels wink
grown ass man confession the dark knight
man of steel and bvs number one the only
three superhero films to still
bring a tear hell yeah
hell yeah we try our best to be honest
you cry uh yes i don't remember
calling in the dark as much i was in the
darkness like 15 [ __ ] dimes
like 15 to 20 times at least and i don't
i don't think i ever cried
i yeah i can't think of a moment that
would be the emotional to that degree
but maybe hey maybe something touched
you in a special way i mean there was
some anguish about like you know
rachel's in peril but you know but there
is something in each one of the snyder
films that has made me cry which i find
kind of interesting yeah yeah they seem
to i mean hone in on on
trauma and overcoming thereof and
actualization despite the things that
make you feel alien
john young if you think about it
the lex luthor scene was only to set up
a movie
what are your thoughts i mean there's a
kind of
quite a bit of [ __ ] that's here to set
up a movie yeah man that is probably the
most
direct thing that just seems like it's
only here to set up a movie it's
probably the only the most direct thing
uh whereas like martian manhunter
actually serves a purpose in the plot at
one point
yeah whereas this doesn't it's just like
oh damn remember lex
remember let's go check up on him and
set up a sequel or set up the batman
movie
i don't know i mean if they ever want to
make their batman movie would ben
affleck
i think it'd be really cool i don't
think it's ever going to happen like
that's when i just don't think it's
going to happen because it seemed like
ben affleck
wants to let it go and they're already
on to the batman they're already on to
the yeah but
um i feel like it was great to at least
see it in its original context because
it is
they think about like this the justice
league they're not going to continue
that
you gotta put the actual post credit
scene was that scene with some change of
dialogue
yeah you might as well just get the
other one
with what it really was yeah you know
the actual color
the actual lighting and the actual
dialogue you know might as well
boom justin jorgensen
um let's see here john campia i respect
him
said steppenwolf is as bad in this as he
was in the theatrical
what he is so much better than this all
due respect john campia
yeah what the [ __ ] pick up some great
dick
nah i mean that's that's for this fair i
mean you know
he's still a villain doing stuff i i
don't know i can't i could not
disagree more with him yeah honestly i
don't i don't
don't agree with this assessment at all
i like john campion
i like him a lot i mean he's an actual
friend of mine like we sometimes
will hit each other up and text but he's
way worse than the theatrical but
but john can't be a my friend if i was
on your show right now i'd be like
sorry bud i gotta disagree i do not
agree yeah i disagree with you
if you were to text me i'd be like what
the [ __ ] john i can understand you still
not caring for him but he's not the same
no any at all yeah way wrong
andrew andrew mcgregor jared leto has
been great
people basing their opinion on his
cringy tattoos jared himself was putting
forth an
awesome performance
well i agree getting rid of those cringy
tattoos
absolutely works yes yeah that does i
don't
even think i need a [ __ ] explanation
for it i'll just roll with it i think
you do
but release the air cut yes more tattoos
in the air cut
joseph she is 5
000 years old everybody is younger
that tickled me so
man that that funeral digging scene is
just so much better
i didn't even mind it in the gym it's so
weird to be like scenes i
actually kind of liked in the justice
version and you see the actual scene is
in the zack snyder version
you're like [ __ ] you know i actually
liked it in the justice one but now i
really dislike it
when i see what what it originally was
yeah this is so funny to me
like the the graveyard scene wasn't bad
to me no in the justice one
and then to see what they changed it to
him like damn it
lots what's the selfish [ __ ] ego
stamp was joss whedon trying to label
over that damn movie you know
yeah again in 10 or 15 like i feel like
we can get a lot of the zack snyder side
of the story but
in like 10 or 15 years i am going to be
very curious to hear the
the ins and outs of the warner's side
and the joss whedon side of all this
stuff that happened
tony wicks c2d4 comics thank you for the
support
love love love you cora satusky
satsuki sorry cora satsuki do you think
we may finally get a zack snyder cut off
mystery man i yield my time seriously
though
love you both don't go anywhere mystery
man
you know he didn't direct me he didn't i
i
he's no it's impossible for him to
direct that but i am for the snyder cut
of mystery man bring back kell bring
back janine garofalo and william h macy
and everybody
and paul reubens whoever else is in that
let's do it i'm for it
thank you cory yeah that's really sweet
jan
martens shout out from brazil
what do you guys think about lois
pregnant how much time has passed since
vbs
a few months it's only been a few months
a little bit of time they have some line
in there that's established
there's some time pass here it's been a
few months but yeah
we talked extensively earlier about lois
being pregnant
love the baby baby origin story baby
origins i mean i think it's like such a
cool little nugget of an easter egg that
you have to like really pay
close attention to the scene to notice
it because apparently the visual
of her being pregnant kind of flew over
people's heads is it ours included we
learned it on the stream
and even though there is that close-up
shot on the pregnancy test
it's it's like maybe it's just the
background thing in the drawer that's
alluding to what could happen in a
sequel
but uh the fact that she's established
to be pregnant i did not
no yeah so i love that little nugget
cozy thank you so much
that's a really sweet comment love your
feedback
life of nate barry's dad was the same
actor who played dr manhattan
in zach's watchmen movie and i wanted a
reverse flash tease when barry talked to
his dad anthony
starr should play him homelander you
would be
great but i don't know i don't want him
to be typecast
yeah that's a superhero daddy
that's the thing is if he steps into
another superhero arena i would want him
to endear me then
i say casper van dien casper van bring
back casper vandy bring him back he has
reverse flight i want
cass i weirdly want him i weirdly want
casper vanden to be reverse flash
christopher hyde i thought we answered
this question would you rather see a
justice league two or a feature
nightmare movie
i feel like a justice league three would
give us the future nightmare movies so
the only way to get there
league is jail i'd rather see justice
league two so we can get to a future
nightmare movie
miles dorsey not impressed favorite part
of the movie right under barry reversing
time those are those are two
fantastic moments such a badass line
how's outstanding
i mean but it doesn't top i'm all for
truth
but i also love just but i also love
justice
we're the justice league and we stand
for the american way
leaf uh leech live reactions do you
think jared leto redeemed himself we
talked about this earlier but just a
quick recap
i think that he has earned um
a liking to or love in a lot of people's
eyes but i don't think it's enough yet
i think it's a vote of confidence it's a
vote of confidence and a lot i think
some people just still couldn't get on
board for it
but i do think there are a lot of people
who were able to get swayed over to the
possibility of what he could do in a
future installment
so i think i do think um
right now we're uh right now he's on the
right path
i'd say to me it's like he had
everyone's attention in a bad way
now he has everyone's curiosity that's
true
this true pram this is your warning i'm
gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna hide you if you keep
doing that
three two two if there's another comment
that comes in from
i'm gonna i'm gonna block him i'm gonna
ban him
i'm gonna ban you prim oh people want to
see you
get some justice and you're banned all
right
no one knows the yeah go all right
all righty dude if you have to go go man
we didn't know we'd be on here this long
either
um amanda dardy still haven't seen og
justice lee but cyborg was literally my
favorite character in this with the best
story i can't imagine not having a
feature my god i cannot imagine watching
this in a reverse order
yeah i mean you could make a good vlog
video telling us what that experience is
like but also if you don't have to don't
do that to yourself
i can only imagine yeah i don't know
anyone who's done that yet
not enough time is fast do it do it and
report back i don't know anyone who has
been like you know as i watched accident
adjusting and i got so curious i got to
watch the other one
i want i want to hear the opinions
though i do all right someone who if
you've never done a reaction before this
would you be doing this to yourself you
i would love to see a reaction video to
that do it to yourself
amanda do just do it amanda amanda we're
telling you
do it joe snapper even though this is a
justice league stream if you could both
make your best evan peters mephisto pun
may be tied to justice league right now
that would be cool well obviously it's
joe snapper who's mephisto who's
stepping in here who's wanting to
um you know
yeah the reference that we know we can't
pay out
yeah yeah christopher hyde thank you so
much buddy
do you wish they had more martian man
hunter in justice league would you like
to see a dedicated movie for him
um i i don't think we needed more
martian
manhunter in this movie i don't think we
need a dedicated movie for him
but i i if we if we do get a sequel to
the
proper justice league 2 i would
undoubtedly love to see
love love to see more martian manhunter
that's for damn sure yeah absolutely
i mean this film his presence doesn't
really beg
more or less really to me but yeah like
a solo
expansion on his character would be
sweet bedford enterprise thank you
christopher hyde
thank you christopher bedford
enterprises guys
this is in real time we're like four
hours in streaming
this is the longest ever done this is
the long one this is the snyder
i don't think we're gonna film those
godzilla clips
something tells me we might not film
those it tells me we're pretty
we're pretty tired oh my friend brandon
showed up oh good
all right guys give me one minute
one minute one minute oh and just in
time to set up an eric horstmann to get
a little pregnant one second
one second we'll be i'll be back in one
minute get a little check
i'll check in with the chat really quick
here
how are you guys doing over here the mcu
will fall in his
name see that's the thing though is like
i want to see them just continue going
off
further and further into their own uh
uh collective aesthetics thoughts on
superman's return scene man i thought
that
it plays a lot better here and i mean it
almost puts you more into his
shoes being brought back and sort of
bewildered and having this sort of
immediate reaction
um and yeah everyone's like just the
tangibility of everyone being like yeah
no it's working oh [ __ ] this really
didn't work this is bad
you know like i thought that was really
tangible uh in this
i love that uh uh joss whedon's name is
great
because uh you know it's just enough
that you see like josh weldon you see a
lot of good misnomers on jos
whedon's name uh and yes justice have
been served
uh i don't know what that means joe
rogan fell in a volcano i hope he's all
right restore the snyder verse
yes agree uh uh let's see
joe rogan is not dead apparently uh so
that's what yeah john
uh we're at eric horstmann my friend
you're all gonna be so tired after this
week
and stream love you all thanks for all
you do get something to eat pizza
yes eric i will get some pizza later
thank you eric horseman for your love
and support you [ __ ] rock and i love
the [ __ ] out of your ball sack
oh your balls are the best balls uh oh
snap
issues with cyborg actor issues with
flash actor bat flag wants to move on
wbs wants to sever caval how can they
continue in justice league
money and the fact that hbo max is the
one who are obviously calling the shots
these days
yeah and h.o max was the one who was
like i don't know what warner bros was
thinking
let's do the snyder cut clearly there's
a fan base for it clearly people want it
all been hbo max and hbo max if you can
get
hbo max to want to do it they have way
more authority
over warner brothers at this point in
time especially with the success of this
clearly they knew what was up it's all
in the hands of hbo max
anthony thank you thank you oh snap much
love
anthony giandalietti watching this movie
was a pure it was a mixture of pure
happiness to see this amazing movie and
being angry that they chose to not use
this version four years ago i think
everyone can relate to the shoes that
you're standing in that's the echoed
feeling that's happening yeah
and and just seeing this makes it all
the more inexplicable that that happened
to begin with
that's what's what i love about this
experience is watching how so many
people are like
i didn't think it would be anything
worth it and come to watching it i'm
realizing like why the [ __ ] would they
why the [ __ ] where they cut even this
out there's so much they could have
still
kept yeah if not four hours you should
have at least kept this you know and
everyone has a kind of their own opinion
of
what should have been kept i feel like
the cyborg stuff is the most commonly
absolute vodka amanda doherty's back
from bruce and trust to cyborg reaching
out
to martian manhunter wanting in i
thought there was an overarching theme
of connection punctuated nicely by that
shot of them coming together at the end
exactly 100 with that finale
everyone was necessary even when
superman showed up to punch
like take out steppenwolf like it flew
into freaking uh aquaman
like they were all taking shots at
steppenwolf and even like wonder woman
holding the lasso down and gripping it
with aquaman helping her out like such a
great
moment that whole sequence was about
connectivity superman to flash to cyborg
batman bringing them together like and i
love how it was
batman was the leader and the one who
brought them together and that's the one
who brought them together but he's not
even really the one in the he's like not
around
for the steppenwolf [ __ ] yeah and that
beat just rang so much more true him him
being like i've spent so much time
trying to
divide us and and now all i want to do
is bring us together and it really
communicates frankie j can we address
the pregnancy
kit in lois lane's nightstand and do you
think the group bringing back clark set
the vision in motion that cyborg had the
future in
is now the present thanks dude um
oh interesting i mean we've talked a lot
about sometimes what about the pregnancy
and do you think the group bringing back
clark except the vision and motion that
cyborg had the future is now the present
yeah oh yeah when he's talking about
seeing the dark side events and the
apocalypse war and all that uh yeah i do
i do think that's exactly what he was
referring to was that he had a fear
barry misunderstood no as now or
something like that or a go
yeah so he so i think that's what
cyborg's biggest worry was
that sharma is it just me or does it
seem like dc
fans are afraid to say that zack
snyder's justice league is better than
lots of most
uh lots of if not most marvel films i'm
a fan of both
but so happy for dc i mean all it's all
subjective and it all depends you know i
mean some people
automatically think zack snyder's
justice league is like the king of them
all
and the best one and a lot of people a
lot of critics have said this is one of
the best dc eu movies
undoubtedly it is it is so yeah i don't
feel like i feel like if you're a dc fan
i don't think you'd be afraid to say
it's better
no no i feel like you'd be shouting it
from the rooftops unless you
are like upset about the interpretations
from comics or something like that but
uh all right what we got here question
marks
question mark snyder understands who the
justice league is mythical
gods absolutely but i think he does
capture the humanity of them pretty damn
well
absolutely as well soap tape
if stephen wolf wanted to go home he
should have gone to danny the street
from doom patrol
that would have been cool dude
i mean you've got to be a way to get
dude patrol more popular if you guys
have not seen doom patrol [ __ ] watch
doom patrol yeah you don't even have to
sign a petition
let's go watch her waiting to be watched
i gotta finish
it but it's it's great hey guys i really
want a blue beetle and booster gold
movie set in the dcu times
jordan rothmeier time travel buddy cop
movie that ends with them in bruce's
nightmare
i mean i'd blue beetle they're working
on a solo movie right now and my blue
beetle familiarity is
bigger than booster gold but i would
love to see blue beetle brought to the
big screen yeah
it's about time get a latino hero
is he latino yeah isn't he i thought
that was one of the big kind of
chinese he's definitely chinese they're
all the same
he's yes people ask me what's your
ethnicity greg oh you're filipino and i
go
shut up they're all the same they're all
they all look nice white they're all
bundled into the same category
white and other yeah
aidan dardy hey guys can't stay long ah
it's okay you're probably
man you're probably not even here
but i totally would love some some more
loose directors vision dc stuff i'd love
to see a more
underrated cosmic villain film can't
think of one but james gunn for that
cause why not love
from alaska holy [ __ ] watching us all
the way from alaska
dude i would never go to alaska yeah
i would love to go to alaska your life
must be miserable
i think i mean look
we got the snyder cut if we can get the
air cut as well
it's going to set zack snyder's release
insider cut is kind of just this one
one thing right now but if we get the
air cut
and that also ends up good it's going to
set a precedent oh yeah
like that that is the precedent oh my
god that right there was like okay i
guess we're doing this now this is just
what we do when a movie sucks
we're just going to release the
director's cut and assume that version
is good
and it'll stop once the director's a
real director's cut is like
okay that's that's pretty bad it's weird
it's like it's it's so not the precedent
but
at the same time there are parts of it
where i'm like well if you could use
stuff you already have and make it
better
maybe in some ways that's honoring your
investment in a more quality qualitative
way
anyway fred skull some of you guys are
surprised we're still alive
you were you should be fred skull
not hating on leto but his joker cameo
and the snyder cut reminding me of zach
galifianakis
lego batman joker that's not unfair
hey that's your opinion that's your
opinion and by the way lego batman movie
is one of the best batman movies hands
down
oh my god the office mega man
league book it he'd do it yeah i think i
think batman could take them on
i think he could win absolutely that's
my favorite part of watching that scene
when superman's back and they're all
trying to take him down
and then batman shows up like all right
none of them were able to do this i'll
get through there
i'm rich i'm rich
let me buy your house back what can we
work out i'm sure there's a deal we can
fix he starts [ __ ] him up and then of
course lois shows up
beautiful moment and i like the way that
scene play there's more that happens in
one of my favorite one of my favorite
parts that was not in the joss's version
was when the flash charges at him the
second time
and then superman just like he makes
that eye contact no no not the icon
after that it's when he flashes charging
at him oh and then all
superman does is just moves to the side
and that's when flash
charges into a flying aquaman yes yeah
yeah
great part so much faster bobby stevens
watching the film i was in love however
i was waiting for that scene like no
man's land and wonder woman
when flash ran back in time tears loved
it i mean there's just so much in here
oh yeah it's an overwhelming experience
yeah it's a gift in a lot of ways it's
an indulgence
zack snyder spider thank you bobby
stevens zack snyder spider-man film when
start petitioning it we see that
petitions can get anything done
spider-man no home ever patrick jerome
de vera thank you so much for your super
chat my friend
twos in my voice slowly but surely 2
double h i like how flash
added a sense of urgency absolutely i
felt like they all did
i mean just flat flash definitely did
because you had like a [ __ ] second to
make a decision
well and so much comes down in those
split seconds like especially the end i
feel like that was
i feel like especially because of him
charging up and everything that happens
with that like that definitely added
more urgency to this cut than the
previous gun for sure ryan knew some who
do you think in the
is in the pod in superman [ __ ] when
flash looked disgusted looking at a
person in the pod
well zack snyder
i had uh we talked about this earlier i
think um i think it was just some
like they said that there are people who
are trying to escape from krypton but i
don't think they're all significant
characters
like one of the empty pods of man of
steel that's an illusion
alluding to super girl at least that's
what zack snyder said
and so the others are just people
there's plutonians a planet full of
people you know so people think we're
just trying to get off yeah but i think
all the important people we've already
kind of
just trying to get off man um jacob
guteau ellis loved ray fisher and amanda
mod
and mira draining the blood from
steppenwolf excited for the reaction
highlights thanks guys for making me
smile oh thank you for making us smile
and yes amanda mott i'm glad she's
getting some attention for this is
beautiful
and i just love the fact that we're
doing this in the most opposite reverse
way possible
reverse flash we're doing initial
reaction
putting our thoughts on a man to mod
heavy ass spoiler talk and now go watch
how we felt about it when we first
caught
and join us this is like the most
opposite way of presenting
our experience with this yeah man it's
non-linear all right it's outside the
box
release the reaction highlights
the swifty you must watch this video
snyder cut a journey good to know we'll
bookmark it
i'm copying and watching now our own
time
all right here we go and never speak of
it but we'll be touched
thank you ricky ricky diaz been a fan of
y'all since 2014
love y'all's work how you feel about the
actor please me kelly kobrakai
is interested in playing the blue beetle
i would love that
miguel i think he's a badass actor i
like him a lot i mean they freaking want
to get the guy who plays robbie
in there as someone else i think he's a
robin sure why not i forget or reverse
but yeah they're trying to get them all
uh to be i'm refreshing this to do the
last of
the super chats then we're at the end
here yeah finally we made it
we were not there we made it we we
we made it how close are we
we're sorry
we made it we made it we we made it
okay okay okay good the end is in sight
though the end is inside we are cutting
again in case you missed it
we're cutting you off the end of the
super chats has arrived
no more generosity please appreciate it
guys you guys rock
let me go check if my friend is here all
right yes yeah my in fact mike t
54 says joss decided to cut your stream
to two hours he
did what a d what a d that joshua
everyone's questions
what a d and mike t 54 is a follow-up no
less
i am so glad they got rid of that bs
parademon smelling fear as a fan of the
justice league cartoons and comics that
alone drove me crazy in 2k17
that's one thing that i we haven't
touched on at all the parademons i
actually think the parademons
were um i think the parademons were a
lot better this time
they served a purpose they need they
needed the parademons to actually sniff
out the
the the motherboard box they they do
most of the every time they come back to
steppenwolf he's like
i don't have it yet but but the parents
are going on they can smell it
somewhere they actually felt like a real
necessity a necessary part to
um to this movie and i loved the way how
a lot of the practical sides of them
were fully realized they felt like body
they felt like a horror movie esque yeah
they felt like actual parasitic
foreboding creatures you know they
actually were scary let me check with my
friends inside
oh yeah this is this is the real [ __ ]
you guys this is it
this is us look at there
ooh okay where did our chats go where
did our chats go
all right all right cool perfect
a plus we're gonna do this guys we're
gonna so do it we're gonna be
[ __ ] great hit that like button hit
that like subscribe if you're not
subscribed and eric horseman
just for the glitches lol love you
we love you eric horton you're you're my
glitch
is dr fake going to be in the next
justice league to tell the league their
fate
yes i think batman's gonna be there to
play dr fate because clearly he's got
all the premonitions
yes he's the guy he'll be the one to do
everything's revealed too in advance
captain spoiler butter x thank you for
the little on
set director's chair awesome gonna be
you one day gregory alvarez and you
john humphrey oh that's that's kind
claudia
rogan is it me or did batman seem a
little too happy
i thought batman seemed hopeful here he
might feel like a bit of an antithesis
from going from really dark brooding
unhappy batman to this one
but i think it's kind of nice to see a
more hopeful side of him and i felt like
it flowed well for me personally it
flowed really a good transitional batman
yeah his lightness in this movie read to
me as a guy who
looked back and went oh man i was really
angry back there yeah
yeah nigel c davis just want to say that
you guys are awesome hashtag restore the
snyder verse
you're awesome yes we must restore the
snyder verse
soap tape greg is mullet superman and
john is leto joke god damn right i'm
mullet superman
that was terrifying that was terrifying
not terrifyingly accurate
but terrifying in its own way i don't
know jared leto has this like squeaky
door
he seems like in pain he does like
laughing
do you like shift on the bullet and
that's what makes each laugh form
mike t-54 never send a boy wonder to do
a man's job
that is a [ __ ] in line right there
absolutely
you really just twist that knife down
yeah man
it's like i love what i love about the
joker batman scene is joker knows batman
needs his help so he's just going to
keep twisting that knife even more
just keep provoking him like this is the
ultimate time to torture him
oh yeah i think that is a really cool
context of the scene
al b thoughts on a cameo that snyder
said would blow hardcore fans mind
martian manhunter was super dope but
thoughts on who you guys think it would
have been
that's true i mean i thought it was
martian manhunter it is
at least that's how everybody has
treated it in
in things i mean that he's been he's
come clean with it suppose it was
supposed to be green lantern but he they
changed it to martian manhunter at the
end so
i'm pretty sure that's what the i think
the answer is right there
i mean to me martial manchester wasn't a
big surprise only because of the fact
that it was leaked
ages ago by zack snyder himself but the
fact that we had martian man under in
here i thought was incredibly rewarding
to go from like storyboards being leaked
on the vero app to now
it's pretty incredible [ __ ] vero tara
halfway taro hey for
real this is real oh my god hey john
this is your roommate from your freshman
year
love your show man because so yeah oh my
god matt matadores bruh
oh once you get a youtube channel going
now your friends from freshman year want
to hang out with you right
now that's right hey we have two
adventures bro we had some adventures
good stuff
took me a while to realize it was you i
i yeah i have way more hair now
superman stopping uh steppenwolf's axe
was bad ass dude that
that is that is so cool and the thing
about taro
is uh one of my favorite memories of you
and i mean you know it's been a long
time but one of the most distinct
memories of you was was one particular
party night where you were in a superman
outfit
oh hell you had like the fake muscles on
and stuff like that
you tied it in john but yeah i'm gonna
have to hit you up and i'm glad you
enjoyed the movie and thanks for
for popping into the stream it's i never
would have imagined this
um and if you have disc four of my
family guy let me know
ryan newsom what if in the future of
sequel justice league snyder film
instead of lois that it was actually
martian manhunter in a plot twist
oh wait a minute that's a lot of
implications whoa
what are you saying that they like
superman was [ __ ] martian manhunter
yes this whole time with the impression
it was lois lane and martian manhunter
was his mom this whole time
she she conceived the whole virtual
manager wanted to do let's be the woman
in clark's life that's right man
he's he's been with uh paul kent since
the beginning he's actual clark's mom i
used my powers for sexual and intimate
experience
i just wanted to know what it was like
from the woman's perspective
i don't think that's the case man
somehow so no i don't
but i appreciate the comment no i know
you're not implying that but i
to answer your question directly without
any sarcasm no i don't think that's the
case
baby milo thank you love you guys keep
up the great contact what do you think
of zack snyder
being banned from killing batman much
love for milo
i mean i feel like
even more reason to do zack snyder's
justice league because if you actually
kill batman and his
it'll make it easier to watch your
[ __ ] robert pattinson batman do you
believe it right
yeah make it really easy to say goodbye
to ben affleck so i think it totally
works
ah karl marr top three scenes top three
scenes
okay man all cyborg's backstory the
whole history there
um the whole finale fight with
steppenwolf up
right up until [ __ ] the head gets
lopped off that's probably my favorite
sequence of them all
and um god you know trying to just think
of a favorite scene right at the top
demuskira i think it would be the
themiscura fight he was going for the
big ones
yeah that was scarified yeah
the crazy action of the crazy moving one
of those
monkey pants monkey pants how do you
think
pattinson will compare to bat flick
they'll be the same
i think patents oh man i think pattinson
is gonna
has a big bar to clear here i feel like
he's gonna be one of those
bruces that has like a percolating rage
under the calm surface
that's just the sense i get whereas bat
fleck has a rage
but he doesn't seem as like he's gonna
explode all that well
pattinson's young where's batfleck brent
brandini this is my vaccinated
i've been trying i've been trying to uh
yo
is he in frame hold on as we're nearing
the end of ours there we go that's the
frame you gotta lean in here
don't worry there was 1300 people here
earlier now it's only 690 so
it's not a big deal no pressure less
pressure
you want to help us read some of these
so have you guys seen the snyder cut
they haven't seen the snyder cut i have
friends who are not into movies [ __ ]
you don't like movies so and yet you're
here on a movie channel
i've known we've known brandon since
second grade i've known johnson's first
i knew him when he was a baby we've
known since two years we're alive
all right guys we're gonna wrap up this
stream in
absolutely five minutes i promise to
tend to you guys
properly shit's going down olivia i love
you thank you for keeping my men company
yes yes you guys look so good i want to
buy a car from both of you
they're vaccinated it's safe they're
totally fine they're [ __ ]
vast brah they got the good [ __ ]
it's us who's behind adrian browser
adrian bauscher have you all seen the
comedian blow with zack snyder so i was
watching it again last have you seen it
no oh it's hilarious john i'll send you
the video
please i will not ruin it for you but if
you go just look up comedian
and zack snyder just typed it in on
youtube on your own time okay
it's this hilarious real clip of a
comedian who didn't realize he was
roasting
zack snyder oh yeah it's a great clip
great clip oh wow what a crazy amount of
super chat thank you
jeepers thank you what a great super
chatter man thank you
guys late in the game late in the game
we're wrapping this
up you guys rock matthew roche do you
think
uh do you guys think jj abrams should
probably not reboot superman now wb
should probably take a step back and
reconsider everything i feel like
there's some weird internal [ __ ] war
happening here
like warner brothers like buried
the snyder verse is so passionate right
now
yes i mean we probably want to see the
superman
for another few years but i still think
you should put that [ __ ] on hold
yeah i forgot to put it on hold put on
hold until you figure out what's going
on and how these two
fractures of the universe fit together
yeah you know people are saying the
stream how this is the longest room i've
ever had it's also the most i mean the
fact that
for the long for a few hours we were at
1300 to 1400
viewers and now we're at 650 after four
and a half hours it's pretty incredible
for us so i'm pretty happy about this
we're almost done though uh yeah i agree
like yeah i think they should put it on
hold man
yeah until it can exist without having
to elbow anything else
the initiative all this talk about barry
but i haven't heard anyone bring up
strobe lights save he did
loved that the normies chats aren't on
the side i just acknowledged the normie
jets inside
that's what i was doing right there all
this talk about barry but i haven't
heard anyone bring up this trump light
sabe
he did also just wanted to once again
campaign for center to direct
a fantastic four movie i need it i know
some people
want a fantastic 405 snyder i don't
think he's the pick for that he's the
guy
i do think he can make an incredible
daredevil movie though likewise
but yes the strobe light save was pretty
badass everett
baker justice league two with keanu
reeves back as john constantine
and ryan reynolds green lantern i think
in your flashpoint movie you gotta do
that you have to
how cool would it be to get spider-man
three this year and then flashpoint next
year
and they're all just course corrections
yeah but movies about all right
different multiverses and paying off
great casting in search of a better
movie
yes okay with that do it yes please but
i think kiana rush
ought to return as uh john constancine
i'd want that more than uh ryan reynolds
green lantern
absolutely 100 andrew mcgregor
hits the blunt so
martian man hunter lets superman fight
three kryptonians by himself
that's a great comment that's so true
yeah man
where was john john's this whole time i
mean like i said
you know i i felt like the choice of
harry lennox being martian manhunter
i think that came in in bvs
i don't know if it was always the plan
because when i watch man of steel i
don't see any martian manhunter but when
i watch
bvs i could see how this guy is probably
martian manhunter
and you know in the final moments where
he shows back up to bruce part of me was
like
the hell were you the last two hours man
you had to have noticed with all your
abilities that some huge [ __ ] was
occurring on planet earth
tyler hague love you buddy just i love
you too man tyler hey gave me a great
ass ps4 that's how i played every game i
played in the last few years
omni media love you omni great reaction
channel
he's already uploaded his reactions for
snyder cut and for falcon and winter
soldier so give this guy some love he's
working his ass off
never sleeping sacrificing the quality
of a good reaction
just to get the added up go check it out
his reactions are genuinely great go
check him out
justin striplin a new zack snyder
justice league version is coming out
soon and it's the justices gray edition
snyder confirmed there's more joker
batman interaction has the we limited
society alive
i can't wait this never ends let's do
another reaction
every cut react to every cut
let's do it this is the new blade runner
but hey i
i will say i am excited to see it again
in black and white i really do like when
they try that and if that's the way he
really wanted to do it i can't wait
i feel like that's the main way he
wanted to present it it just seems that
way right
dude it joins the mist and fury road in
movies that people wished were in black
and white
into the chat jaden one day we will do a
live stream reaction
uh for a movie alexander truffle hey
guys love the con
contact just finished the movie oh my
god
you know when we when we touch each
other they love that all right i love
the content guys really content
is content i would love to end this
stream by signing this am i supposed to
sign this shirt can you tell me if that
or am i supposed to keep it blank the
associate producer yeah tell me if i'm
supposed to sign it do we need a sharpie
we got one right there we got a shark
i'll sign it here right now and i think
it'd be a perfect way to end the stream
when it's time to end the stream
yes 80s tears hey batman flash scene was
very reminiscent of tony stark and
spider-man
that's true although you know it's got a
diff i mean in the sense that they're
a grown mentor and mentee but i feel
like their dynamics are a bit different
i mean tony's much more of a jokester
than bruce
both are rich for their superpowers
though
i didn't feel like it was too much i
don't think it was that similar to be
honest
no i didn't think about those movies at
all during that
um odis driftwood this
is justice love you guys otis we love
you love your namesake most people might
have
might have been like no we gotta
continue this stream some other day
we're we're gonna finish all these
questions never stop never stopping
gerardo padilla in the chat said you
[ __ ] we do uh
okay wait am i supposed to sign it keep
it white sign it
sorry auto correct okay keep it blank
you gotta sign it you [ __ ]
sign sign sign i think it's up to you do
you want to sign it
i don't know if i should sign it i mean
it'll make it
your justice league shirt your associate
professional
edward is keeping his blank i think i'll
keep him
you have to say you need to sign
corresponds to satsuki
tradition sign okay i feel like the
common consensus is to sign it
well because itsuki wants you to sign
corus atsuki's name
i know i'm just saying i think the
common consensus is i gotta sign this
shirt okay
we're almost done here i will sign it
all right movie talk
i think it's okay lots of slow motion
looking ha ha
all right movie talk there is some slow
motion but at the beginning of our
stream like the very very [ __ ]
beginning of the stream one of the first
things we were talking about was
the what i think snyder beautifully
captures wood slo-mo and the necessity
for it
so go back four hours ago and you'll
find that answer but you'll find that
answer
you'll find it somewhere but i
appreciate you being here
all right let's take one last look here
this is the last of this this is the
last
stream labs and i'm going to sign this
shirt then i'm going to go hang out with
my friend who's patiently waiting while
my fiance keeps him company
all right gabriel rodriguez is up i like
the movie but i feel the hype the fact
that it's for fans and the love that
zach is rating it higher than it
is i think there's a
handful of better dc films like joker
and wonder woman what is your fave
i mean right now it currently might
actually be bvs ultimate edition
for me okay i just declared it it's my
favorite one
all right it was like number six when i
before i revisited it but now it's like
number one for me it still might be bvs
ultimate
but i don't know bbs ultimate and one of
them are still kind of tied but this
i don't know that's all snyder all the
snyder verse films are on the top for me
and
the dceu it's either this or birds of
prey because i think
i think even wonder woman when you watch
man of steel and bvs ultimate then you
watch wonder woman
you can definitely see zack snyder's
influence all over that film
like that's not to discredit anything
that patty jenkins has done but you can
see all of zack snyder's influence you
can see it's grown out of that cd
alexander truffle sorry auto correct
other words love the channel love thank
you thank you
love you buddy love you appreciate it
love you
it's almost time to sign the shirt all
righty who do we got
here we go we got two more left and
that's the end this is the end
milo you guys are absolutely amazing
please keep with the great work always
excited for new content on the channel
what do you think about zack snyder
being banned from killing bad boy just
we just answered that question
what would you rate the film out of 10
much love milo i would say
for the ambition that it is for the
length it is and how
i mean i'm like a 9.99 out of 10. yeah
i'm i'm sitting at uh
just because i'm like you know still
processing and and you know
allowing for time it's it's eight and a
half what a crate
final question to end that off on right
there yeah point nine nine out of ten
for me
eight and a half now it's a ten out of
ten it's eight and a half or nine right
now but i feel like it could go ten
to only walk away with i got a couple of
nitpicks and they really are just
nitpicks
yeah out of four [ __ ] hours that's a
10 out of 10 for me yeah
this gets real close no real complaints
if it's not a 10 it's high up because
i'm like this delivered on stuff i
didn't expect and gave me flavors i was
hoping for but didn't expect like yeah
there's there's so much greatness here
hitman hudson hello cool people it's
been so long my review of the snyder cut
is
110 needed the legion of superheroes aka
dc's best characters
don't worry it'll come one day one day
you'll get what you want
glad to see you back in here and this is
the real last the real
last frank d and we have to cut off even
though no more
no more no more superman i'm going to
sign this shirt
but i appreciate everyone here i feel
like we talked about everything we
talked about the story
there hasn't been anything we haven't
talked about is there anything in the
snyder cut we missed
comment now or forever hold your piece
but just do it in the regular chat
frank dx hey guys thank you frank dx
thank you i love this channel i've been
watching for the past years all to say
is we're all proud of zach for making
this movie happen
cyborg and flash killed it hashtag
restore the snyder verse
[ __ ] yeah frankie yes restore the snyder
verse
amen to that and after all these years
i'm glad it's paying off
jack beaumont hey guys been fans of
yours since i was at college when you
first reacted to force awakens
would you want to see a harley detson in
jl part two no
yes you want harley to die i want to see
a death scene she's not going to stay
permanently dead they're going to fix
things
okay let's get it holy death scene all
right fine why the [ __ ] not at this
i'm sure some do all right guys look
i'm gonna sign this shirt oh that means
you're gonna have to take it off
i'm gonna take off my shake it off
see i don't get a bar on the back of
mine i just get a quote
i don't get a bar on the back of mine
cool white bar to sign
a new line another rhyme
nah dude you're [ __ ] fit greg now
you're you're fit greg now i've fixed
her than before
nah dude fat greg is dead bury him
oh look at this look at this if i could
tilt the camera without destroying
everything
oh look at it go look at it go
uh oh damn i couldn't get you associate
producer
greg alba hell yeah dude zack
thank you that's wonderful look guys
this is the end of the stream
my only friend the end this is the end
of the stream
once i took my shirt off we lost every
viewer i know they were just too
intimidated oh no i thought it would
look better
everyone's like we can't watch porn on
youtube
it's okay guys no one's gonna tell your
mom made it to the end listen
everyone who's been here this entire
[ __ ] time okay we got one more
all right they're never really ending
guys i love you all
i love you all so much
uh saying side note can't wait we gotta
honor everything
can't wait for godzilla versus
mechagodzilla love from miami can't wait
for that either
we're going to be watching it next week
boom keep a lookout for our coverage
thank you my friend for supporting the
channel thank you thank you thank you
thank you to everyone who's been here
thank you to everyone
for showing your support this has been
the long ass live stream
longest you've ever done undoubtedly and
also our most
despite the fact that we've had to
restart this live stream on three
different ones
this has been our most successful live
stream we've ever done so thank you guys
so much for sticking around for so long
thank you everyone who's here from the
beginning you guys [ __ ] rock
i am out of breath i gotta go spend some
time with your shoes
seriously you guys rock we'll see you
guys soon thanks for making this special
be safe take care much love end the
stream
john end it for reals intentionally this
time
end it and